ant-man and the wasps post-credit scenes
finally answer the question where was
ant-man in Avengers infinity war yippie
Kay we be lovers it's Jan here and today
I'm breaking down the two post-credit
scenes in ant-man and the wasp
explaining their connection to infinity
war and how they set us up for Avengers
4 if you're new here I do regular
superhero videos Plus and kicking off a
new Marvel giveaway make sure you're
subscribed and leave a comment about the
movie to enter spoilers ahead for
ant-man and the wasp and infinity war
the mid-credits scene opens with Scott
Lang preparing to head back into the
quantum realm on a mission to collect
quantum healing particles Janet Van Dyne
warns Scott to stay away from
tardigrades and not get sucked into a
time vortex once inside the quantum
realm Scott collects some healing
particles then reports he's ready to
come back
hope counts down his return over the
Mike five four three
but then the line goes dead as the
camera cuts back to work hope Janis and
Hank will operate in the quantum tunnel
we see the remains of three clouds of
ash falling two little piles on the
floor basically the Pym family has been
dusted by Thanos his snap at the end of
Avengers infinity war it's a really
ominous moment when you hear Scott's
panicked voice over the mic as the
camera pans through little clouds of ash
he realizes something's wrong but he has
no idea what the scene is also a
chilling reminder of the infinity war
post-credit scene where Nick Fury and
Maria Hill evaporated into ash in New
York it's especially tough to watch his
hope only suited up as the wasp in this
movie and Janet Van Dyne was only just
rescued from the quantum realm and now
we have to see them dusted wasp will be
in Avengers 4 however Evangeline Lilly
has said she's only going to be in it a
little which is disappointing as it
seems she'll probably be limited to just
scenes where she returns with the other
dusted heroes now there is a glimmer of
hope no pun intended in Janet's last
words to Scott about time vortices in
the quantum realm Avengers 4 is very
likely to be set several years after the
snap in a film that I expect will show
the surviving Avengers adjusting to a
decimated world and figuring out what
they can do about it
Marvel has cast a currently 16 year old
and the Furman to play an older version
of Scott's daughter Cassie in Avengers 4
which means I expect
that once Scott realizes that there's no
one at the other end in the real world
to bring him back he may try traveling
through a time vortex this could take
him into the future where he meets an
older Cassie and then together they
visit Tony Stark to tell him about the
quantum realm and the Avengers then
tried to figure out how they can use
time travel to fix what Thanos did this
would tie in with Avengers 4 set photos
of a man in New York with Iron Man and
Captain America with each of them
wearing a similar looking device around
their wrist another possibility for how
Scott escapes from the quantum realm
could tie in with Captain Marvel I
expect a reason will be revealed in her
film as to why Carol Danvers hasn't been
around or available during the various
crises we've seen on earth such as the
Battle of New York sokovia or infinity
war itself it could be that she's in the
quantum realm herself and the beeper
that Nick Fury set off to contact her
and the infinity war post-credit scene
may be able to communicate with Carol
there ant-man might hear the beeper
while he's stuck there too and he and
Carol might both even meet up in a
Captain Marvel post-credits scene that
sets them up to meet the Avengers in
Avengers 4 another possibility is that
Scott simply gets stuck in the quantum
realm for several years and learns new
secrets and survives there just like
Janet did his daughter Cassie could
eventually find out where the mobile
quantum tunnel was located and so she
turns it on again to bring him back out
what's also interesting in this credits
scene is that Scott was collecting
quantum healing particles these were
being gathered to help ghosts however
there's a chance they could also play a
role in restoring the heroes who had
dusted in the Faneuil snap there is a
second post-credit scene which while
short does provide a little more
backdrop for Avengers 4
after all the credits of rolled we snap
back to Scotts house which seems to be
deserted everything is quiet except for
the dissonant tone of an emergency
broadcast playing on a TV screen
indicating the fan off snap as Trudy
kicked off a crisis this sense of an
ease is followed with a shot of the aunt
who filled in for Scott during his house
arrest playing the drums it's an
uncomfortable moment watching the ants
drumming away as he seems oblivious to
the catastrophe around him and just to
unsettle us even further as the screen
fades to black a title card pops up with
the words ant-man and the wasp will
return but a little question mark is
added after a second or two
we can't take this last bit too
seriously as I think Marvel is just
gently trolling us because as I said
earlier it's already been confirmed that
Evangeline Lilly does return in Avengers
4 now I'd love to hear your theories on
Avengers 4 and have you seen Ant Man and
the wasp what did you think of the movie
let me know in the comments and make
sure you subscribe to enter my Marvel
giveaway I'm working on new Marvel
videos so until then tapleft to check
out one of my videos youtube thinks
you'll like or tap right for my full
Marvel playlist including infinity war
if you enjoyed this a thumbs up and your
support is really appreciated thanks for
watching and see you next time you
became movie lovers